Kairat summer on is a former inmate of a
Chinese reeducation camp he got out of
the internment facility in March and is
now in Kazakhstan it's an important day
for him he's meeting a team from Amnesty
International to speak about his
experiences we had to sing for hours
songs like without the Communist Party
there would be no new china songs
praising multi-tone and we were forced
to repeat slogans about the greatness of
President Xi Jinping and what a great
place China is to live in some go to
fadh2 Davonte on earth for that Sam
Mohan is an ethnic Kazakh
he was born in China where large numbers
of Cossacks have disappeared into camps
along with Weger and members of other
Muslim ethnic minorities the official
justification combating religious
extremism is all about bring Washington
for them to us that that your Chinese
you have to accept that it's a national
unity is size to make you feel you a
part of the nation you don't need to
keep your own ethnic identity is just
really like ethnic cleansing
practice the Kazakh authorities have
warned some ahan of the long arm of
Chinese authorities but he wants his
voice to be heard need to have the
courage to tell the truth if we don't
share our stories of what's going on
then who will
that's why I'm speaking out samer Han is
in Almaty a city around 300 kilometres
from the Chinese border few former
detainees have made it here
we do not know exactly how many people
are being detained at these camps
international organizations estimate
that the number exceeds 1 million there
are no verdicts and no sentences
releases entirely at the whim of the
camp administration many Cossacks have
links to China and many have relatives
in the camps just saying the wrong word
or expressing your religious beliefs can
lead to detention for many inmates the
only hope of release comes from
amnesties efforts on their behalf this
man was arrested on a business trip I
don't even know if he's still alive my
son is 12 he asks me where his father is
every day even his teacher has started
asking questions
news from across the border has become
rare for Muslims in China any contact
with their relatives is simply too
dangerous